so I went to school at Belmont
University and it was like a southern
Christian University that had low
standards yeah that's amazing what it
says on their website too
does it like a home of mediocrity
mediocre people exceptional prices uh
like
[Music]
all right we're live
we're doing a q a session we decided
this kind of last minute it's like when
a substitute teacher comes in and they
roll out the TV on the trolley and
they're like hey guys today you know
what I decided
I want a day off oh no no sorry I wanted
you guys to watch this movie
no it works out because frankly I think
people like this and we like the movie
too it works it's a win-win and so yeah
we we have to do very little work and
people like it let's just get right into
it we're gonna keep each question at
around three minutes uh which is not you
don't have to worry about me going over
it's Sean let's do it Ben what do you
got let's do a little q a so basically
the background is we both tweeted out
what questions do you have
and we got a bunch of them in the uh uh
on the tweets and uh we'll see where we
go we had we I think we have like a
hundred hundreds of them and we selected
maybe 10 ish of each uh or of from each
of our twitters and we'll see which ones
are interesting
all right go okay uh from someone named
new BET a pretty basic one what is your
opinion on sweaty startups
all right here's my opinion I think it's
cool I think any way you can get your
nut you get it that said that sounds uh
the philosophy you've had since you were
a teenager or what yeah get that nut uh
I think if you can get it it doesn't
matter which way you get it get it and
there's lots of examples of everyone
succeeding in all different types of
Industry personally I think making money
digitally is significantly better
because it requires close to no capital
in some cases you can work from anywhere
there's been times I've sent an email
from my phone and it's made a whole
bunch of money and I think that it's way
hard way harder to make a million
dollars a year from a brick and mortar
business than it does uh digitally I
also think that the lab laptop class I
saw Elon Musk call Tesla headquarter
employees the lab laptop class I think
those types of people of which
most of you are including myself we want
to do stuff with our hands and I think
it's significantly better just to make
money on the internet and then all your
free time go get a hobby because if you
go and talk to a blue collar worker they
sure as hell don't want to be there
um so I'd rather be in the situation of
like being able to choose to spend my
time doing it the other way versus
in this question the guy said uh sweaty
startup makes great this is Nick our
buddy Nick Huber so Nick makes great
points about not wanting to compete with
Stanford grads generating real cash flow
and getting rich the slow way I agree
this might be the best video what do you
guys think so
I think this whole Nick is great and
Nick and I think you're totally right
that
however you want to win win and there
are many many ways to win if anything if
this podcast teaches you one thing it's
how many different ways there are to win
um but given that given that there are
many ways to win you better choose the
one you really want and for me I'm like
I might as well choose the one that is
most ideal the most in tune of the
lifestyle I want I don't want to go
worry about the roof damage at my self
storage facility or that the you know
the the 15 an hour employee called out
sick and there's nobody at the front
door now
to take customers today like I don't
want those issues I'm happy bearing a
different set of issues uh and so that
you know I think you got to choose how
you want to win and I also think this
whole idea of like you don't want to
compete against Stanford kids
this is like a great sound bite but it
doesn't matter it's one of these true
but not important I used to say this all
the time to pissed everybody off in the
office I'd say that's so true and it
doesn't matter yeah which it's like dude
I just want to win like my high school
conference Championship I don't need to
worry about you saying exactly you know
what I mean like if I get there nobody
who's doing digital like an internet
company is like God these wretched
Stanford kids keep keep beating me it's
like dude I haven't seen a Stanford even
if I did see a Stanford kid you've seen
those dorks that's not a problem like
yeah give them a wedgie and push them
out the way nerd like you don't have to
worry about these guys Knuckles still
work noogies are very effective but like
it's not the Stanford kids that are the
problem if you fail in the Internet it's
because it's a noisy place and you
couldn't get anyone's attention right
you die of starvation not murder when it
comes to startups internet startups and
so if you're if you're failing it's not
because the Stanford kids beat you it's
because the market didn't want what you
what you had to offer and I don't know I
like sitting behind my laptop I haven't
worn pants in you know 450 days this is
the way to live and by the way you have
or had you know you could talk about it
whatever you want but you've had an
e-commerce business which is have 20 uh
brick and mortar as in you have like
people you got to go see we have
physical products we take a warehouse we
have things like that more than 20 yeah
whatever it is uh and then you also did
milk road which one was better
a newsletter letter that
this wrote that we pushed one button to
send to you know 300 000 people and just
printed profits from month one yeah
that's the one that I think that was the
one I liked the best the one that after
a year we were able to sell just like
that because there was no
none of that Sweat Right they call it
sweaty startups for a reason so uh I've
done both the one thing I will say
though real estate has some amazing tax
perks so that that he does have that
going for it and we'll wrap it up by
saying and this sounds like I'm making
fun of Nick and Cody both of whom are my
great friends Cody Sanchez so I'm not
but
ask them which one's making more money
the digital stuff or the brick and
mortar stuff right um I don't actually
know the truth so at least 20 startup
guys you guys are pretty active on uh
Twitter and uh excellent courses and
these online courses
Revenue versus that laundromat
right so I would I would ask them which
one they think is better but who knows
all right what do we got all right next
up uh we'll take it from the top someone
named it block mates asks what's the
most interesting business you've seen
that didn't take off and why do you
think that was
go for it so there was this app back in
the day that I saw when I saw it I was
like this is
this is gonna hit it was made by these
Russian dudes
um and it's called povio and what povio
used to do was every other social
network was uh like I post photos so
Facebook was like I go to a party I post
an album of photos then Instagram was
like yo I'm on the go I'm at a cafe I'll
take a photo of my cappuccino and it all
had this kind of like look at me uh I'm
kind of bragging about my life thing and
I've always said that social networks
when a social network hits it's not
because of a feature it's because of a
change in the the privacy policy right
so like Facebook was the first time you
used your real name on the Internet
because you would do it with other
college kids who went to your same
school that's why Facebook got your real
name your real relationship status your
real courses put you get you to put it
online
um Twitter was like hey you don't have
to be my friend you could just follow me
I can't even I don't even have to prove
you just follow me that's a change in
privacy policy uh Snapchat change of
privacy policy I was like yo this is a
disappearing photo that it's private so
every great social network has a change
in the privacy policy and povio had a
genius one which was you would request a
photo from someone else so I would ping
you and it would open up your phone and
it would go three two one and it would
take a picture of where whatever you're
doing or wherever you're at and so you
could kind of be like yeah it's a way of
saying what's up
but the person would default reply with
a photo and I was like this is genius
they're getting people they're giving
people even more excuses to take random
useless pictures this shit's Gonna Fly
and sure enough on the first college
campus it started to work and it was
growing
and then it just kind of faded away it
never really made it and I I still
believe in this mechanic of
if somebody made this app where you
would you would basically be you're
basically saying what's up and they're
replying with a photo and you're
basically pulling the photo from them
rather than pushing it online I think
that's kind of a game changer but I was
wrong it never it never worked
I'm looking at their app description and
their app page in iTunes and it says
that it only has like five reviews so it
never took off but the funny part is is
that you know how there's like
screenshots of the app it's a very
clearly it looks like a kid on the
Stanford campus taking a picture and the
way Stanford's in Palo Alto this is
Santa Clara yeah I don't know well I
don't know what's there but like you
don't got to worry about those Stanford
kids see it's no big deal it doesn't
work
um but mine is um Dorsey so it didn't
work out it's door the word door then s
e y
um but I've always wanted I've been
looking to invest in companies that have
a good chance of making buying a home
online possible uh I'm like I'm a firm
believer that
people will end up buying close to
everything online and there's only a few
categories but that's not the case it's
like Hardware so like like Home Depot
still crushes it because like you don't
buy a screw on the internet and then
homes it's another thing that people
don't buy online no one's figured it out
yet this company has not worked yet and
I still think there's an opportunity for
a company to work in the space where you
can buy like you'll make hundreds of
thousands of dollars or millions of
dollar purchase on the internet I think
that's gonna be a thing do you remember
when Mark Cuban bought uh a jet on eBay
and it was like all the rage like all
freaked out I didn't even know this uh
yeah so when he sold his company
broadcast.com he you know became a
billionaire and he bought a 50 million
dollar Gulf Stream jet on eBay and
people were freaking out which it's not
even that like that's not even that
interesting if you ask me what's only
interesting that it's a big purchase but
like you know a jet like if it's the
same model you kind of know what you're
gonna get and like the condition is like
Fair excellent you know what I mean I
just asked Google's AI I think I said
what percentage of Home Depot sales are
online and it said 2022 60 of its sales
were online so even Home Depot is
selling the majority of products online
versus well if it's if it's if it's
Revenue then yeah I believe that because
people will order grills but like when
you want like a five dollar like bolt
you usually just go there and you'll buy
like 10 of all different sizes you know
what I mean see like which ones actually
fit uh but uh yeah I'm into like things
that can't be sold or aren't being sold
online yet that should be and I think
that homes are one of them what else you
got Ben
all right here we go
um this is something we've talked a lot
about recently but what does enough look
like for you
you've got a much better answer than I
do just just for reference I put a
bullet point in and I wrote out what my
answer might be or like a a blurb and
mine's this like long thoughtful thing
and then Sam's like Sam I'll just answer
yours for you it just says I don't think
there's ever enough
whenever you explained your point of
view that I'll sound like here's why I
thought that there was like there's been
multiple times in my life it was like a
hundred thousand dollars five hundred
thousand dollars where I thought I won't
worry and I've hit a lot of different of
these targets and I still worry there's
times where I worry less for a little
while but it like have you ever heard
the idea of like
have you ever seen um You probably
haven't but there's like stories and
studies of people who lose a lose a limb
and they're pretty bummed for like six
or yeah they're bummed for like six or
twelve months and then they go right
back to being they're like okay I'm back
at it I feel fine uh I think it's the
same with like a lot of money stuff
where it's like uh you make it the
amount that you thought and then you go
back to like where you were and I
believe that to be true that's why I
said Never Enough well I'll say a couple
of uh other other ways I think about
this so yeah come on Indie and Guru yeah
let me just I mean do you got your
wisdom cups out everybody because I'm
about to fill you up yeah are you gonna
do you need to sit like a Indian style
to tell the story
exactly
take a deep breath in first before I do
this
um all right so vipassana so so Paul
Graham did this thing where he created Y
combinator which is basically the most
successful company in Silicon Valley
besides like Google and Facebook and uh
did he just retired he's just left and
he moved to like the woods in England
and he just writes code in his cabin
with his kids and
writes you know poetry and paints and
well goes for walks and I was like this
mother this [__] thinks he's got
enough huh and I was like you know dare
he leave the rat race all of the rats we
were shaking our fist being like you get
your ass back in here and um and I got
inspired by that and I was like okay so
what is the like what's the enough State
not money but like what would I what is
my version uh so instead of thinking
what number would I feel like is enough
because I think that's a trap I just
thought about like
if I felt like I had enough or what I
want to go do and then I thought maybe I
could just go do that thing so
here's what I came up with two things I
said uh I heard this Naval quote which
was retirement is when you stop
sacrificing today for an imagine
tomorrow
and uh that hit home and he was like you
know what that means is that the the
moment you do things in your day that
the act of doing them is the reward not
like you're doing them today sacrificing
for some future payoffs that are going
to come at that moment you are free
and uh and I was like okay that's the
goal the goal is to be free meaning the
goal is to on a daily basis do things
that the act of doing them is the reward
I'm not doing them for some future
rewards and I said if I did that what
what types of things would I want to do
what types of things is the act of doing
them the reward itself and here's what I
came up with I said
I think that having a big podcast is
actually the best job in the world and
I'm obviously biased here but I've also
tried a bunch of things and this is the
best uh if you have a big podcast that
means you're famous but you're only
famous amongst nerds which is kind of
the not annoying way to be famous uh
it's like all the good parts of being
famous without the bad
um you also get rich but you didn't have
to chase money
um you get to create content but you're
not like the annoying 24 7 vlogger who's
got their phone out and ruins like their
actual life trying to create content for
some audience because with the podcast
like we sit here for like two hours a
week in recorder three hours a week and
record and that's it the other 165 hours
in a week we get to do whatever we want
we don't have to think about creating
content and we don't have to get hurt
while we're doing it like if you watch
it I don't constantly one up myself and
like like that dumbass YouTuber who
crashed a plane on purpose for views and
now is going to jail
um you're not competing on an algorithm
like Tick Tock where you get this hit of
Fame and then you're forever chasing it
um but podcast great you just talk
you're unscripted you're unedited you're
talking to a friend or somebody you
admire like if it's a guest
that seems like the best job in the
world and then
for fun I would basically coach a
basketball team like Mighty Duck style
and I would want to just [__] like chill
out and just shoot the [__] in a
writer's room for like a TV show or a
comedian
um or teach at Stanford twice a week I
think those are the things that I would
just do for the pure joy of doing them
not for some future rewards and to me
I'll have enough when my day is mostly
[__] like that
why haven't you tried to get a teaching
job or a coaching job I haven't put
enough attention on it like this
question made me think about it and made
me think oh why don't I just go do that
now and often life is that simple like
it's not that there's actually any
barrier in the way it's just I didn't
put my attention on what do I actually
want oh yeah okay I can probably just go
get that
one good excuse is you have young kids
so it's like once they go to school
maybe uh that would be it yeah I'm not a
believer in that I think it's really
just a matter of like
I didn't put my focus on that's what I
really want okay then go get it
by the way there was a good Paul Graham
thing so this guy tweeted out there are
very few second times Founders because
anyone smart enough to succeed the first
time isn't dumb enough to do it all over
again
Paul replied he goes anyone smart enough
to succeed the first time is still
running that company and then our friend
Akita go yeah wonder what happened with
that washed up via web founder and what
he's doing these days that was Paul
Graham's first thing and he goes touche
Paul so like you know even even the
smart guys like Paul can can get things
wrong once in a while so he says he's
got enough but who knows I actually do
believe that he does but
um I think your answer is better than
mine uh it is about enjoying the
experience more and whenever I was like
running my old company the hustle I look
back at it and I'm like I wish I would
have enjoyed that more during the
process but it's a very challenging
thing to do well I'll just ask you one
thing are you okay with knowing that
you'll never have enough before you
answer that let me just put it the other
way which is if you feel like you'll
never have enough that sort of is to me
that means you're never really free like
the most fun interactions you know this
is like when you meet with somebody you
want nothing from them and you need
nothing from them like those are the
best interactions with people there's no
more freeing feeling that just literally
I don't need you and I don't want
anything from you I can just be here and
just have have whatever experience I'm
gonna have uh versus the opposite when
you want someone's approval or you need
them to like you or you need them to
hire you those are the most stressful
interactions and so to me I think if you
want to be free you got to believe that
there is such a thing as enough I think
we're you're thinking about it
differently than I am so let's say that
you're an athlete let's say that you're
a weightlifter or let's say that you're
um a comedian you're Hassan minhaj
you're your buddy is he ever gonna be
like I'm funny enough I don't need to
improve my craft anymore I don't think
so I think he could find a a bit of
contentment of being like I'm on top of
my game I'm doing awesome and I can
always get better and that's kind of
when I say It's never enough that's what
I mean if my craft is building if my
crap is building companies that means
that there's always more that I can do
to be better but that doesn't mean that
I'm unhappy or not uh satisfied with
where I am fair enough fair enough
um all right Ben let's go to the next
one if you could go back to your college
days what is the one thing you would
have done differently knowing what you
know now that's from Sam Faber so I was
a huge idiot in college and not even
like the cool idiot I was like ah man I
was I was just being dumb just going to
parties having fun with my friends late
nights you know it's like wait did you
love it or are you saying it was bad
it's like for me I was just I was just
doing nothing I was a do nothing idiot
and uh that's the worst kind um and to
me now that I look back I'm like wow
college is a gold mine you can make
lifelong friends you can meet future
business partners even just you know I'm
a business junkie now I wish that when I
was in college I had been launching
businesses I got a captive Market of
students who I understand who I can
reach that are just living literally
living in this bubble waiting to be sold
products uh and I could have been
working on my skills then versus I
started working on my skills after
college
um you know there's alumni that like I
didn't realize how powerful it is just
to be like hey I'm I'm also I also go to
Duke you went to Duke 35 years ago I go
there now and they're like cool you want
to hang out and it's it like it's that
easy to connect and so now I look back
and I would say I would mine that gold
mine I was just sitting there eating
Chick-fil-A on top of a gold mine I
didn't even really look down and realize
what I was sitting on
um the only smart thing I did was I
studied abroad which is kind of a thing
you really want to do at that point I
went to Australia
what would you you didn't go to Sydney
did you did yeah yeah man study I think
Sydney Australia is the greatest City it
is the greatest City it's the best place
to be like a 19 year old it's the
greatest place on Earth my biggest
regret is that I didn't take High School
seriously enough to get into some of
these amazing schools so I went to
school at Belmont University and it was
like a southern Christian University
that had low standards yeah that's
amazing is what it says on their website
too
is it like a home of mediocrity
Joker people exceptional prices uh like
back then it was very expensive it was
very expensive and it was like such a
mediocre thing I like when you say you
went to Duke like I I I envy you so much
because at least you got like even the
basketball guys were like the best and
then a lot of your peers were very very
smart and I bet you met like a lot of
people from even though it was in the
South I bet you still met like tons of
different like foreigners people from
New York City people from California I
didn't get to meet any of those people
so I regret that the first like Jewish
person I met was when I moved to San
Francisco at the age of like 22. like I
didn't know like it was just like pretty
much just white people and so I wish I
was like around moral of like a global
uh group of people and so that was one
of my big regrets I also wish that I
took seriously the idea that the things
that you do in college aren't that
important they don't have to be like the
thing that you do but if you take your
hobbies seriously
um it's a really fun time to try on
different personalities and things like
that so I wish I had a little I took I
wish I took that more seriously um I
totally agree with that part which was I
thought in college the thing is your
classes and the result is your grades
but actually that's completely backwards
like the thing is the people in the
environment that's the one thing you're
never gonna get back and then if you
really wanted a result you wanted to
like you know take it seriously the way
to take it seriously wasn't to get a
pluses or like you know be an amazing
chemistry major it was actually like hey
this is four years and after this I'm
supposed to figure out I'm supposed to
be like doing a job and pick a career I
should dabble I should go and like
sample like it's Costco and it's noon
and I should go sample a bunch of
different way things that you could do
meet a bunch of people who do that thing
and I should take this time to figure
out what do I actually like to do and I
wish colleges were oriented like that
because colleges are oriented around the
opposite assumption it's like pick what
you want that means you must know and
then put your head down in focus and
it's like that's the wrong time to focus
uh you should be dabbling at that stage
do you have good credit I'm okay credit
like I have good enough credit
dude I wish I would have
um so I didn't like get a credit card
until I was like 24 and then I started
my company and I would Max it out
constantly and then I would and I would
always like pay it off like before I had
to so my credit card utilization was
always like a hundred percent and I
didn't have a long credit history and so
I wish I had there's a very practical
thing I wish I had a credit card at the
age of 18 and I used it for everything
and always paid it off so I could build
credit history I don't have like the
most the best credit because of that did
that come back to bite you why do you
need your credit so bad you're trying to
get loans or something what are you
trying to do what when I tried to buy
the house that I'm living in now I
couldn't buy it my wife had to buy it
one because my credit history wasn't
long enough which is crazy uh and it
wasn't like fantastic I think every once
in a while it's in the 600s and then um
be because you're a business owner
buying a a house and getting a mortgage
is really really challenging so I can I
couldn't buy it fair enough all right
what do we got all right this next one
is uh have you had a deal not go through
when close to finishing it if so what
did you learn to do better how did your
mentality regroup to start the process
over not for sure but I feel like the
sellers are trying to tank this business
acquisition which is supposed to close
on May 31st that's from Mackenzie Reed
this is a great question and the I
accidentally interrupted you but he said
um I feel like sellers are trying to
tank this Biz acquisition which is
supposed to close on 531 I want to
address that but first I had a deal go
through I think my NDA is up but there's
a recent Media company that went
bankrupt that tried to buy the hustle
and we got to a term sheet and it
completely fell through or we got to an
Loi and it completely fell through and
there was like three others that I had
lined up and it also felt through and I
was devastated so I changed my opinion
to
uh this like any deal that I have it's
going to happen to it will not happen
but I will act as if it's going to but
just assume it's not going through and
then if it does I will be happy because
most fall through but to address that
last question of I think the sellers are
trying to tank this Biz acquisition I
have that exact same attitude when I
sold the HubSpot and I and then one day
I just told him I got to know the woman
uh who is I was working with that
HubSpot and she was like look you don't
understand we're worth 20 billion
dollars this deal is really not a big
deal to us like this ain't gonna do
anything for us I mean it'll do a little
something but just so you know we
already got like board approval to do it
which means I told my boss and that boss
told their boss and then that boss
reported it to 12 people who are like
billionaires and [__] and so if this
deal doesn't go through all that means
all 12 of those people have to like
change something and and then more so
I'm gonna look stupid and my boss is
gonna look stupid and this other boss is
gonna look stupid so because we're a big
publicly traded company if we say we're
going to do something we're going to do
it not necessarily because of it's It's
a logical good deal but because I don't
want to look dumb in front of all my
bosses so we're going to do this versus
when you sell to a smaller company or
like an individual who's got money I do
feel they will always try or not always
a lot of times they will nickel and dime
you or they will try to dock you but I
don't necessarily necessarily think a
lot of times they're trying to ruin
something but I do think they will have
ulterior motives which is like I'm
trying to learn a little bit of
information about this company so I can
start my own or do all these other
things but when you sell to a big
publicly traded company I think nine out
of 10 times it's not in their best
interest to screw you
that's a great answer I'm the same way I
go into every single deal assuming the
deal is not going to go through because
uh as Emmett said to me birds fly fish
swim and Deals fall through that's what
they do deals fall through it is not a
is it not a uh you know outlier or
exception or like disaster when that
happened oh a deal did what it does
deals fall through that's what they do
baby like what you're worried about
sit your ass down why are you crying
that's how that's my that's how I talk
to myself when I when I get like
emotionally attached to a deal so the
emotional Detachment is key all right
well how do you do that part of it you
gotta you needed to be having a
bulletproof mindset before you get into
an m a transaction it's too late when
you're in the m a transaction to be like
all right guys I'm gonna toughen up this
here brain to be able to like operate in
a very like tricky circumstance where I
might get life-changing money or it
might all fall through and like you know
that's a that's hard to do then you got
to train before that
um you know that's the first thing
second thing is
um I not only do they fall through
that's also not fatal when they do
um in fact every deal I've done has had
a fall through moment if not two and so
that is my my rule of thumb which is
that every deal that does close
both there's going to be two walkaways
along the way you're gonna walk away or
they're gonna walk away that's gonna
probably happen twice you're gonna hit a
wall twice before this deal actually
happens where it feels like this deal is
dead or it's simply not happening or
there's just a very very low chance that
we get over this this hurdle have you
announced or have you said have you ever
mentioned I'm not sure if it's ndi the
other two people you almost sold to
instead of twitch uh I think I said
before like we got pretty far down the
road with Facebook and that we also had
a couple others that were Facebook we
had that were were like out one hour
away from accepting the deal and
finishing it
um and one of the good things that they
did tell me was same thing you just said
about HubSpot uh so twitch is owned by
Amazon and the Corp Dev guy was like
look I'm sorry we've been so slow
and I'm sorry we're not the like we
can't just give you everything you want
in terms of price
but here's the good news we will not
retrade this deal which is what it's
called when you come back and you try to
get that that's what they told me second
negotiation once everybody's fully
emotionally invested and you're like but
actually now I want to change this but
then you think like oh you're just a
doctor you tell everyone that their kids
are like doing great or like they look
they look cute like you know what I mean
like you're just you're [__] that's
true who's helping me help me get
through it and he confirmed that he was
an investment banker he'd done 100 plus
transaction he's like yeah these guys
are both of them Facebook and Amazon if
they give you an offer they're solid on
that that will be the deal that goes
through there will be if it doesn't
close us because you didn't disclose
something that you then come out later
with or you change your mind it's not
going to be because of them that's the
good news of these big companies the bad
news is deals get hung up or delayed for
all kinds of terrible reasons
um so so you know I just sort of expect
a deal is always going to go slower than
you want is most likely going to fall
through and even when a deal happens
it's gonna break up twice before it
happens that is the rule of thumb and so
I gotta do I got some great advice from
biology when I was doing uh the milk
Road sale
we had a couple offers and one offer was
higher on the money and the other offer
was a little lower on them or like you
know I would say what was it like 25
lower on money or something like that
let's say and he goes okay well you're
saying you're you know you want to take
the hire deal that makes sense but let
me ask you one question and he goes
um are both of these deals at the same
point meaning have they both been have
you been talking about the same amount
of time have they done the same amount
of diligence so far have you gone back
and forth the same amount of times with
them I said no no the lower deal we've
gone all the way through and this higher
deal where it he just came on super you
know they came on super fast and and
they're really eager and we got the deal
done fast I was kind of excited like
these guys seem really committed because
they're they're they're they're moving
really quickly here and he goes okay so
you need to apply a discount then
because the offer is not 25 higher in
fact it's probably half as high once you
apply the discount of
this deal doesn't doesn't close or falls
through you're going to turn down an
offer that's solid for an offer that
might be a slightly higher but hasn't
done the two fall throughs yet and so
he's like you need to apply a discount
he's like if I'm honest if I'm
discounted this it's at least 50 based
off of just the normal way that M A
deals work this deal will not be the
exact deal that closes if it closes at
all and that was very Sage advice and it
ended up it ended up playing exactly out
we tried to go with the higher offer and
then sure enough more stuff came out of
the woodwork that gave us hesitation and
then we were like look this is not as
solid as we initially thought or like
you know we can't just take the headline
numbers we have to take into
consideration the ability to close and
The credibility to close and um that
changed the calculus
and the way you get around that is you
say the bad things up front I think
um as best as you can you say anything
that will ruin it as early in the
process versus as late in the process
this was great advice you gave me you
gave me this advice when we're going
through the milk Road process you go
um here's what you're gonna do because I
was going to dinner with them and I said
you said here's what you're gonna do
you're gonna go there and you're gonna
say the following you're gonna say
awesome sounds like we're all excited
now I'm going to tell you every reason
you should not buy this company I'm
going to show you every skeleton in the
closet now to save ourselves some pain
later and if anything here scares you
I'm happy to either explain it or if it
just doesn't work then you know you we
can know now and I was like well that's
the opposite of how I would have
naturally approached it so so tell me
more and then I did exactly that and
after the deal went so we did that and
then after the deal went through we did
a postmortem like hey that's how you
know these buyers are smart they're like
what could we have done differently in
our buy and I said same what could we
have done differently in the sale and
they were like one of the best things
you did was at that dinner when you just
told us anything that was bad about the
company and you just proactively said
here's all the skeletons in our closet
or anything that might look ugly to you
he goes that built so much trust for us
that and he's like from there we we
weren't even like we weren't worried
about those things because it built so
much trust and um it's a very selfish
thing you got to do it in a
non-manipulative way you can't actually
do that and then leave out the real
skeleton that that shit's like the
opposite of interest
um so so that definitely worked and got
confirmed but it's a it's a it's a
win-win scenario which is you uh get the
deal done hopefully faster than than
slower and also it makes them trust you
which option which is you find out
earlier that it's not gonna work and you
move on you don't waste three months of
time you know dragging it out when you
would have you could have known that up
front if both has been more honest
I agree
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better all right
Ben what do you say all right next
question is do you have any updates to
Sarah's list or any new additions
so Sarah's list is this list it's dinner
for my my wife because it's at this
point it's just its own name but
basically we made a list of companies
where you could join and have a safe job
meaning you're hopefully not going to
get laid off like you would at a 10
person startup or go out of business you
can still get paid a lot in salary and
then still have like maternity paternity
leave and have a lot of these perks and
benefits and also your stock I think our
requirement is could 10x is it 10x so
basically so basically it's based off
your real real story Sarah joined
Facebook she joined Airbnb and she
joined them not like super early when
they were just still in their you know
their apartment trying to figure it out
it was like it was it was working this
was a business that was already valued
at you know let's say a billion dollars
or more and um so a multi it was a
multi-billion dollar company already you
get the fat salary you get the oat milk
unlimited oat milk on tap in the in the
break room you get the maternity leave
you get everything you would want but
also you get a stock package that even
if you're not even like a AI engineer
like let's say you're getting
uh 70k a year of stock
um
if that thing 5x is you could become a
millionaire without ever having done the
the startup route just in a four-year
vest cycle and so and that was your your
wife's story it was inspiring to me and
to you is like I feel like nobody talks
about this but you have to correctly
identify the companies that can four or
five x in the next four years and uh so
we have this list so anyways they want
an update on that list uh but there's a
YouTube video of the last time we did
Sarah's list and we I think we've done
it it's done it twice and we actually
updated that hey a bunch of the
companies we said the first time sure
enough I think the average multiple was
like you know in exactly the range that
we had talked about so now I actually
think it's the opposite I'm calling it
Sarah's Exodus basically there's a whole
bunch of companies that raised money in
2020 2021
um that we're at valuations that worked
when the economy was different the stock
market was different inflation was
different
interest rates were different
and now those companies it'll take you
years to get back to that same valuation
if that I said now I think it's Sarah's
Exodus which is what are the companies
where you just have zombie Equity you
are so far underwater on the value of
your shares that not only will it not
four or five x it's not even good at 1X
you won't even get what you think it's
worth today and you're going to sit
there for four years earning that
useless stock and so I actually think
you have to make the opposite list what
companies raise too much at the wrong
time at the wrong valuation that are
basically upside down and uh and you
basically will go to TechCrunch and you
put year when did the bull markets
basically say 2020 and 2021 as the peak
maybe even a little 2019.
and go through TechCrunch and do sort by
like year search and anything unicorn
yeah yeah and anything that became a
unicorn in that era assume that the
likelihood is is until proven otherwise
right go to go to your CEO and say hey
what is the fair amount market value
what is the actual fair market value of
this company right now
um what's a lot what is the last money
we raised at how much total money have
we raised oh we've raised 600 million
dollars okay so we'd have to sell the
first 600 million if we sold would just
go back to the investors it goes into
nothing to employees and figured how
much secondary did you take and what
type of G wagon do you have
yeah you figure out those things did I
ever tell you the crazy so you were
talking about like going to these big
companies and you can get like all you
can eat food and [__] like that can I
tell you about the craziest thing at
Airbnb so if you go to their they have
like a cafeteria their whole shtick was
that every single thing from the ketchup
and mayonnaise to the Coca-Cola to the
all the condiments the trail mix
everything was made in-house on premises
when there was an office all the food
was made right there on the spot and it
was amazing there was a that's amazing I
remember the same thing happened at um
what's it called Zynga I went to Zynga I
met the head chef at Zynga he ran this
Chef was a manager of like 40 people
that was The Culinary team the internal
culinary team was 40 people at Zynga you
show up at Zynga first of all there's
like 94 dogs running around insane
amount of dogs their logo is a dog and
ever there's two dogs for every one
employee there secondly 40 percent like
a dog fighting pit in the middle like
people like when time's gonna lay in
games Facebook made the album change
yeah there was a little dog fighting
ring that brewed up and the second floor
uh and I went into the kitchen and I was
walking around he's like uh yeah we do
our own butchering and he opens this
like fridge that was like a 40-foot foot
you know like fridge and there was just
like one of the dogs there was just cows
hanging upside down and I was like
you're gonna break that down he's like
yes I break that down every morning uh
what's this on tap There's No Label he's
like that's my homemade kombucha like we
make her own
we Brew our own drinks we make our own
food the veggies that you see that
mushroom it grows on the roof here
and then uh during the tour I got a
little hungry reached into the pocket
had some Cheez-Its I opened up the bag
dude they heard the crinkling of a of a
packaged good in that kitchen
the whole kitchen like it was like I
said bomb on a plane dude I was like I'm
so sorry I don't know how this got here
I don't know what this is put this in my
pocket
do they still have it you think of
course I don't now but although
the building dude the whole building got
sold
buildings sold for more than the company
was worth at the time I think if you
Google Zynga building they owned this
building in San Francisco and I think
they sold it for 250 million dollars at
the time when the market cap of the
company was 200 million dollars yeah it
was either that or more profit than
they've ever generated it was one of
those two and yeah now it's owned by uh
take two who makes Grand Theft Auto and
NBA 2K they own Zynga now yeah I like
those those Chef companies so like
Sarah's list I I think you got to go get
get yourself dating somebody who works
at a tech company with all you can eat
food
what are you doing what's the point no
perks bro
yeah what are the attributes of this
relationship you know what I mean you
need to bring some attributes you better
be uh you know the like Starving Artists
extra hot or you have a company I've
seen how many Clif bars I was like a
like I was the Pablo Escobar of
smuggling Clif bars out of tech
companies for like a three-year period I
had free prosciutto for a year I used to
like I used to I used to call it I
didn't even know what it was I was like
find this proscotto in all the land
dude I use a center to work with
Tupperware containers make sure you stay
till seven
why are you home so early I know in that
Facebook dinner didn't start until 5 30.
it takes you an hour to get home where's
my Pursuit
uh Ben what do you saying what do we got
do you have any Frameworks for
maintaining healthy friendships
especially when you're separated by
distance mine's simple I'm in the phase
of life right now I've got one simple
phrase when it comes to friends No New
Friends if you're in you're in it's a
mental problem for you yeah say no to
everything
if you and you in if you ain't you ain't
what's yours yeah I'm the same I suck at
this uh I apologize to my friends I I'm
a shitty friend to them they know it I I
do feel bad about it uh but you can only
try to be great at so many things at
once and okay I got kids so what are you
still picking which thing you're gonna
be great at
which one's you gonna be
great dad try to make a bunch of money
and then try to get into incredible
shape those are the things I've
prioritized right now and so uh you know
friends had to take a little bit of a
hit there
all right you loser what do you say Ben
what do we got if you were to start a
business based on the quirkiest or most
ridiculous idea that you've ever had
what would it be and why
yours is actually good Sean yeah did you
have an answer for this
no because I'm not like that quirky of a
person say yours
the IQ test is actually a good idea uh
all right so I so
I remember I met a guy who would sell
Stars
like literally like a star in the solar
system for 25 he would name it after you
and I think he would just name it in his
own database
and then there then I saw this there's
this guy who's just been crushing on
Tick Tock I don't know if you've seen
these Tick Tock ads where you he will
they own a small piece of land in like
Dublin or something or something like
that and you will officially be knighted
as a sir
uh like you'll get official title as sir
and you will own a piece like a plant on
this land we got one foot by one foot
you know like plot of land
um so when I saw things like that you
know there's really two reactions
there's most people who I roll and say
this is what's wrong with the world
and then there's me who's like man
what's wrong with me why haven't I done
this and uh that's kind of where I'm at
so I would love to just take time to do
some of these stupid things like I want
to be the pet rock guy or like the
Million Dollar Homepage guy I think that
would just be a lot of fun as a
challenge I have an idea which is uh I
want to create a new IQ test because
like who doesn't want to seem like they
have high you know like a high IQ so I
think you can build like a d2c IQ test
that people would pay to see how how
they score
or just go all in on something super
woo-woo like uh horoscopes crystals
something like that I actually launched
a d2c Crystal Brand like an e-commerce
brand for a month and
um now that I look back now that I know
what actually how e-commerce works that
brand was actually working I was just
too big of a noob to even understand
like is this good why is it good because
people can't return it no no I just mean
like it was working like I was acquiring
customers at a good rate like the I mean
all e-commerce is basically CAC for cell
TV it's just what's the lifetime value
of a customer the LTV compared to the
cat the cost of acquiring that customer
and uh and actually my my LTV attack was
actually good I just didn't really
understand it enough at the time I
didn't trust it enough at the time but
my first Ecom Biz before the one I made
was a crystal one like in my garage
right now I have like 4 000 rose quartz
coasters still just because I didn't
sell again I didn't move that inventory
I shut it down how much did it cost for
you to buy and to sell
uh oh dude these are very cheap to buy
like uh you know the gross margins are
like 75 80 so you know you buy it for
two bucks you sell for ten it's just
like round math right but like in
reality you're selling it for 24 and
you're buying it for whatever that math
turns out to dude that's wild but like
also you don't want to be a fraud which
hey if you're selling crystals I mean
fraud is in the eye of the believer as I
say and uh there are a lot of people who
believe that crystals are good and help
them uh like the reason I had this I got
one of them was I but I'll sell it to
him I went and I read I opened up a
magazine like you know Cosmo or one of
these magazines I was like okay I'm
gonna go look outside of my normal box
for new ideas so I went opened up like
Cosmo and there's like this two two-page
spread about crystals and it was
basically like Adele will not go on
stage until she like uses her rose
quartz crystal thing Kim Kardashian
after she got mugged for her four
million dollar uh diamond ring I don't
know if you remember this she claims
that crystals are one of the like only
things that kept her anxiety down and
soothed her and she keeps one in her bag
at all times Gwyneth Paltrow from goop
I mean obviously huge into crystals do I
even need to explain uh so there was
like this huge number of like
celebrities influencers well and there's
the Adam Sandler movie with Kevin
Garnett where he like buys that you know
million dollar black Christmas that's
right yeah that's right that came out
late after I'd done that but but yeah
basically saw I was like oh if if
Kardashian Adele and like whatever
Jennifer Aniston or whoever these people
are like if they're all into crystals
like trust me you know the perfect
e-commerce customer a woman in the
midwest is going to buy this stuff and
it was actually some chick named Kinsey
yeah so you know Kinsey in Idaho
she wants to buy the [__] out of your
rocks yeah like if you have if you have
like a sign that says simplify or I love
us
you're you're gonna be one of my
customers
um all right Ben what do you say where
are we at all right that one was mostly
for Sean this one is mostly for Sam
which is what were the first five big
boy moves you made at Hampton the first
thing I did by the way bed you got to
say these guys names so people who asked
these questions just Joe Watkins yeah
Joe Joe Watkins he asked uh about
Hampton
um I don't know about the first five but
uh I didn't buy a domain name it was
just Hampton at
hampton.squarespace.com and I sent the
link to a bunch of friends and then they
sent to a handful of other friends and
then I just reached out to tons of
people people would sign up on that page
which it was just a type form and then I
called every single person and I
interviewed them and and me and Joe Joe
did like the back end stuff but I did
the front end stuff of like calling all
the potential customers and I must have
interviewed a hundred to 200 people and
uh I was the one that sold and got us
the first million dollars of sales and
so I called it uh I told I would joke
and tell Sean my calendar looked like a
zebra it was just like constant Stripes
of like these 30 minute meetings with
the 10 minute break 30 minute meetings
ten minute break and I did hundreds of
them and I got us to a million dollars
um that's a good question probably just
laid on the couch and think I hate this
and I'm so excited when it'll be over
one day
um like I mean it's really hard work
it's very challenging
um and then another big thing I did was
I hired a CEO because very early on I
thought this thing is going to be bigger
than I'm this thing will be uh exceed my
personal capabilities and skill sets
very soon so I should hire a CEO but
getting the first million dollars in
sales is what I did for like two months
I would say the other thing you did is
you uh you nailed the brand and the name
um which is
just art that's talent but I think that
you know a name won't break you but it
can make you I think Hampton is a
perfect name because you borrowed The
Prestige of the actual Hamptons and you
uh hired an agency to
do like a nice job with The Branding or
whatever uh so I think that was also
that agency I hired was fifteen thousand
dollars and basically what I did was I
sent them a whole bunch of really old
Rolex ads and I also said my favorite
color is British racing green because
because that's like I I love that color
it's like a lot of old favorite things
also no it's a British racing I love
like I've had motorcycles in that color
I have all types of like uh Toys in that
color I like that color I go make it
look like an old Rolex ad and make it
and use British racing green and that's
kind of how it came to be and fifteen
thousand dollars for you to spend
fifteen thousand dollars like gift a lot
of people a sense of like is that just
nothing for you are you just like let's
just say this you sweat that last
Saturday I drove 20 minutes to return a
spatula to Target for seven dollars
make sure there's not a second one stuck
on there
that's hilarious
um all right what do we got all right
next up is uh this is from Josh Redd who
wants to know what are the three most
common small boy moves that you see
all right so we have this phrase no no
small boy stuff okay what what is small
boy stuff the first rule obviously is if
you think it might be small little stuff
it is but besides that I would say
there's the the three big ones the three
big buckets are the three W's waiting
worrying and wanting
anytime you find yourself waiting to do
something that you actually want to do
that's a small boy move that's a small
boy mentality you're focused on the
wrong things uh worrying same way
worrying hasn't done anyone a lot a lot
of good you got to know how to do worry
I think Sam's worried time is a
fantastic framework for that so go go
look up Sam worry time
um and wanting wanting meaning like
wanting what other people have uh and
really like uh people are their happiest
when they're grateful meaning they want
what they have versus
um
versus you know wanting what they don't
have
um and so I think that if you find
yourself in a state of mind you don't
want to be in and that small boy state
of mind it's because you're probably
waiting to do the thing you actually
want to do uh you're worrying about
something that might might happen that
might be bad or you're wanting something
that you don't have that other people
have you're being bitter you're being
jealous or or so on and so forth so to
me the three W's kind of capture most of
the things that are small boy activities
have you ever heard of this phrase this
is we're gonna get a little Sigmund
Freud on your ass uh external Locust of
control do you know what that means I
have heard this phrase many times and I
never have any idea what this means
Locus is a bug that's where I started
and uh you tell me where to go from
there
yeah you're totally wrong
um but uh so in internal locus of
control means that uh well let's say an
external locus of control meaning is
means the way that you feel and the
position that you are in your life it's
because of everyone else so if you have
an external locus of control you think I
am in a bad mood because the traffic is
bad and it's their fault or I am um I'm
poor because
um the the government won't help me or
everyone's out to get me internal is the
opposite which is I control how I feel
and what I do and where I am in life and
so I think that there's a direct
correlation between like
um like what I consider like a small boy
thing of that internal versus external
locus of control so anything that is
when you say I am the way I am because I
choose to be or I I put myself in this
position I think oftentimes that's uh
when you're more on that Spectrum I
think it's better than when you are when
you're focused on external so anything
where it's like I have to wait until uh
this is ready or or I have to um
please these types of people or whatever
that's typically I think a loser
mentality yeah 100 I I was actually
telling somebody this yesterday and uh
I was like where where do you think the
power lives in this scenario let's say
there's a plant
that's not growing
um where where where's the problem and
you know what do you suspect the problem
is they're like well I mean it could be
the soil
all right so soil so it's the
environment that's the reason that uh
that's a plant sacrament no no maybe it
was just a bad seed
oh so it was kind of like the genetics
of of the seed that that you would blame
for for the outcome
no no it's just not getting enough
sunlight because there's other plants
blocking it oh so it's others it's
competitors that are taking the finite
resource that you you can't have
what what is it what is it that where is
where is the problem and uh and the
answer is really there is no problem you
are the plant just [__] grow like
don't don't blame anything don't don't
feel lack in any one of those areas
um like you want to be ultimately you
want to be the plant that can grow in
any any one of those any under any
conditions from any seed in any soil
with any with any sunlight in any
competition and so um what I find is
that I get along least with people who
really like over index on
they always blame the soil it's always
the it's always this the city's fault
it's always the school's fault it's
always the environment's fault or people
who oh it's genetics I'm fixed it is the
way it is all right or oh it's the
competition they're always taking my
things right it's like those are the
people that get along with the least and
even in myself when I find myself
thinking that way I get along with
myself the least I hate myself the most
when I think that way see you you didn't
know what it meant but you you came to
the same conclusion that you know
hundreds and of years worth of
psychologists it took them to figure it
out all the time thousands of years of
wisdom I just sort of on an afternoon to
just come up with a better version
myself and then I then I find the words
to describe it
and use the better analogy uh all right
Ben what do you say where are we at all
right we got an emotional one ladies and
gentlemen grab your tissues uh Sam
what is in your opinion the greatest
quality that Sean hasn't Sean same
question what is the greatest quality of
the Sam has that's a question from
Griffin Humphrey Griffin good question
Sean's greatest quality
if it is uh I feel like I don't want to
look you in the Island right now it just
closed his eyes should I close my eyes
too it's like it's like there's a ton of
ways that I can take this analogy you're
sitting at a table and somebody puts
their palms out like this and then
you're supposed to put your hands in
there yeah yeah
uh that's weird you don't look people in
the eye when you're doing that just like
complimenting each other and go to the
bathroom I contacted it it doesn't exist
yeah
we need to sit side by side there we go
yeah just the conversation when you ever
noticed when you go to the bathroom with
someone even if you're walking to the
bathroom together as soon as the fly
goes down the conversation stops yeah
the flying or zippers like the off
button
and then you shake and you go back and
the Fly goes up up
right back to the conversations
that's what this is like uh Sean best uh
attribute is that his attitude is always
uh positive so I don't think I've ever
been able to not that I've done it on
purpose but he's I've never gotten them
rattled and he's very very very pleasant
I think almost 100 of the time I've
never seen them get upset about stuff
and that is actually frustrating about
him is that he doesn't get frustrated
sometimes but at the same time I would
rather have that because uh I'm fairly
emotional and I get frustrated easily he
never gets frustrated
um and so I would say that's his uh best
characteristic internal locus of control
baby
yeah you you control your mindset yeah
the locus is inside of you all the time
it never goes outside of you you you you
it's in you so I would say that's easily
your best attribute is the ability to
stay calm and happy no matter what mind
for you would be intensity I think you
do a great job cranking the knob up
whenever you are into something I admire
that and when I look at all the things
that I admire about you like
the way you're self-actualized in terms
of Fitness or the way you built the
hustle or the way you're building
Hampton right now
um the common denominator is the level
of intensity you bring to it so
um I don't think
there's really anything else like it's
not like I'm like oh
you know the reason saying again it's
that internal locus of control it's not
like I'm like Sam's Sam got lucky
because of this or he's got people
helping him and that's why he's winning
or he's just born with some talents that
others don't have it's like I think you
just have a better job at cranking the
intensity to 12 when it's time to if
you're like I'm gonna get in shape
you're like great inject my butt with
trt build a home gym hire hire a
personal trainer hire a coach buy the
best equipment do the wake up every day
do the program when I'm doing the
workout I'm pushing myself to my actual
Max and then I'm doing this I'm
measuring everything I'm posting
publicly so I'm ashamed if I don't do it
you go the full way and it's like the
same thing with Hampton I told you this
like I had had a very similar idea for a
peer group thing years ago I kind of
dabbled with it tried it created one it
was actually going pretty well but I was
like I have Shine the object over here
got kind of bored decided didn't really
think it was the right thing didn't
really see the big picture to see you
take that same idea and do it at level
12 intensity is such a gift for me
because it's like
I get to see a without intensity
approach to the same idea and a with
intensity approach to the same idea and
it just shows what the difference is and
then like that is the difference and so
to me that and I also wrote Sam's got a
code and he lives by it I think you're a
lot more uh
honorable
uh than than most and that definitely
than me and so I kind of admire that too
what code I I don't I don't view myself
as having a code necessarily do you feel
like when you give someone your word
that it's done
yeah it's for life do you feel like that
if someone's your friend they should
fight for you and die for you in any
small slight is a like like a a loyal
stab to the heart I feel like if we're
in public and
you get in a fight with someone and you
throw a punch even though it's your
fault
yeah the the the person it is over and
then afterwards I'll be like you're an
idiot that was really inappropriate but
yeah yeah I feel I I disagree privately
publicly like we we die together yeah
I'm just showing up on time like I
really you have a code I don't even
agree with your whole code I think
you're crazy with something when you go
chase down people that broke in because
you're like no you broke in now we fight
we duel I'm like that's stupid Sam you
should not do that or you're like this
guy's trying to charge me an extra
hundred dollars because of whatever no
we we're taking him to Petty court and
I'm like Sam it's not worth it man let
it go so I disagree with your code but I
love that you have a code because I
don't think I really have a code to live
by all right what do we got
all right really quick let me just tell
you guys the last questions and you say
what what you want to do what you don't
so we got uh creatorpreneurs you're
paying attention to we got pros and cons
of building in public
let's do creative one really quick yeah
who are the creative crater producers
that's kind of a weird one Creator
preneurs you are paying attention to and
why I like Isaac French because
someone who's like creating content but
they're also an entrepreneur they're
building a business around their podcast
or their YouTube or their Twitter
whatever that's what it is I like Isaac
French I hung out with him and I was
like why are you so purposeful with
everything you do he goes That's just
part of our religion we feel that like
we just have to be excellent and that's
how we show that God's Great and I was
like oh okay so like you're I'm not
gonna Panic it's that yeah yeah I like
Jasmine star they're just she's a woman
who has a uh she's got a software
company I've met her through Hampton and
whenever I hang out with her I feel like
uh I'm gonna cry like she's so intense
um and she's like she describes herself
as like a Latino woman from like I think
East L.A and she's like so like I'm
gonna like Crush all these Tech nerds
and I love that attitude
um and I like Jason yanowicz and Austin
Reef Jason yanowitz ruins blackworks a
crypto company that just raised some
money I would never bet against them and
then Austin Reef as I've got no Austin
Reef the founder of morning Brew
do you agree with me that guy's a
straight Stone Cold killer I would never
bet against us he's really impressive
and actually my opinion of morning Brew
because I was friends with you so same
you know the Loyalty test I was friends
with you Therefore your enemies are my
enemies and when you were doing the
hustle I was like okay so who are the
other newsletters those are my enemies
someone go look up their Founders and
they're on my [__] list and now Austin
is a friend and I actually really think
that guy's awesome and he's super clever
and um there's a bunch of people that
are like successful but stupid he's not
one of them he's smart he is not he's
he's he's real
um so he's you know I give him my and
he's young I always forget this I think
he's only 27 still
um I think he'll have north of 100
million dollars before he's 30 years old
is my guess and he's got a mean Lefty
hook shot all right so
um my Creator preneurs I'm looking at so
I try to look at people that are in
different bubbles because I think if I
just look at other business content
creator entrepreneur people I'll become
the the lame the lame Twitter thread boy
copycat wannabe [__] boy that's you
know what I tell myself in my head so
where do I go look instead uh I look at
creators in other categories so I'll
give you a quick example we had uh Danny
Austin on the Pod recently and actually
a bunch of people who were listening to
it I saw a bunch of like feedback that
was like oh this episode wasn't for me
Instagram influencer who cares and I was
like you guys are missing the point like
um yeah she's way more sophisticated
yeah I was like uh the gold there was a
good there was golden nuggets there so
first I subscribed to her content
because when you look at what Mommy
influencers on Instagram do it's a whole
different style of content that you can
kind of Steal ideas from and get
inspiration from that's the first thing
the second thing was every other mom
influencer created like uh my fashion
brand is here buy my dresses for the
summer buy my swimsuits but whatever
same same same same same merch and
fashion apparel she picked an incredible
business which is this uh scalpcare
thing that was perfectly aligned with
her story of why she's famous in the
first place and why people connect with
her it's this high margin thing with
only a couple of skus doesn't have any
of the headaches of fashion it's a
beautiful business and it's crushing
doesn't you know 40 million dollars last
year in Revenue without even you know
pretty significant without even like a
lot of AD spend and so to me there was a
nugget of gold which is what happens
when you align the perfect project
selection like that's an example of
perfect project selection paired with
awesome content creator what what could
that business sell for that should be a
multi-hundred million dollar business
like that should be a 250 million dollar
business if they just carry on
um that is a it's perfect project
selection I couldn't admire it more
perfectly aligned with her and it's a
beautiful business on its own all right
uh others
um
that are more in our Niche so pomp I'm
inspired by his level of output uh the
guy's a machine I'm super weak and
inconsistent with output and he is super
regimented like I think he's ex-military
too so like he is super like regimented
with with output and I'm also interested
in how he's like redefining himself he's
rebranding himself outside of Bitcoin
right now and that's something cool to
watch so I want to see what he does and
what works what doesn't there
um Tim Ferriss also very different than
me he's Ultra thoughtful about his brand
which is the opposite of me like he's
measured he's thoughtful he cites his
sources he is like he does not say yes
to a lot of things he's very picky and
choosy he's the opposite of me in every
way so I like to see what he does
because I want to like
you know I want to learn through learn
from people with different play Styles
and then Steve Bartlett same thing he's
high style so everything Steve Bartlett
does is cool I buy a hat he buys a hat
mine looks shitty his looks awesome uh
you know he well he's also like a 6-1
like pretty ripped looking black guy I
mean of course he looks awesome
everything he does the way he talks is
in style the way his his party's British
uh trailers are done in style his live
podcast show he's got a gospel choir
singing as he's talking or some [__]
like that I even know I don't even
understand it but I just know that what
this guy does he does his style I think
there's very few people just like I
think there's very few people in
business who are funny I think there's
very few people in business that have
style and so I kind of I'm looking and
watching what they're doing and picking
little pieces from their game dude I
always look at Steve McQueen you know
who Steve McQueen is he's like this
actor that he's dead now but he called
him like the king of cool and I like
look at clothes that of he wore and then
everyone wants to dress like him and
then you see like on Reddit someone's
like oh I tried I bought the Steve
McQueen outfit and you look at them and
you're like oh you look like you look
like store brand Steve McQueen like you
know like that ain't good
sometimes people just look like I'll
look at Brad Pitt and I'll look at his
clothes and then I like see people try
to dress like him I'm like dude you just
don't got it you know what I mean like
no matter what I do I will never you're
just better looking than me you just you
got you got the bod that's sometimes
that's how I still feel about some of
these guys and I guess I'll put Steve in
the category when you're when you got
that bod and you got that face you're
that tall you know you're gonna look
good no matter what
fair enough here's a really quick one
someone said
they asked a different question but I'm
going to phrase it they asked one
question but it phrase it differently
which is who do you want to live with
Gary vaynerchuk Elon Musk and Mr Beast
and I wanted to say something
I think they all would be horrible to
live with those all three of those guys
would be the worst roommates only Elon
because he'll just never be there
actually that's the best for me the guy
who's just got the empty room and he
actually gotta you're you're living in a
double but it's all yours like that
that's that's actually a pretty good
good deal I've lived with a handful of
Highly Successful People and I've like
hung out with them I hate going to their
house
their Helms are usually a wreck I hate
it
camera around in this office right now
like people would unsubscribe the
gentleman agreement would be over
people will be like I never want to hear
from this guy again if somebody lives
like this like think of your worst
episode of Hoarders that's currently
what my office looks like it's it's an
absolute mess that's disgusting to me
how do you live that way
I just do bro I just do I don't know I I
don't know how I live with myself like
this this is crazy I don't want to be my
own room your your room's like a mullet
man it looks great like from this angle
but you got all this party nonsense in
the back well after I record this I just
leave this room and so I never come back
and clean it I can't stand that that's a
filth to me I would not I could not be
around that um is that it are we done
Ben did we do it just one more I want to
ask one more all right because why not
Kevin Newman asked who are the three
folks he does m33 but who are the people
that are having the most fun
I love this question I think about it
all the time because you could ask like
who's the most successful
who's the smartest who's the most
popular I'm interested in having a lot
of fun with my life I only have so much
time on this little planet I want to
have fun with it I want to enjoy it and
so I think this is a great question to
ask I got a couple answers but I would
be really curious to hear yours I think
yours would be very different than than
mine does anybody come to mine off top
of your head
Rob Dyrdek and say a few more words
about that
uh Rob Dyrdek when I think of what I
want my life to be it's basically to
have a Fantasy Factory so Rob Dyrdek
um by the way he talked a lot about his
wife not only is she does she seem
awesome former Playmate model not only
does she seem awesome she looks awesome
yeah
yeah no Rob Dyrdek he um
I think he has a ton of fun and I think
that he I think he views I like people
who view business a little bit like an
art instead of like a McKinsey like
spreadsheet dork and I think that this
is his art this is how he expresses
himself and I think he has a shitload of
fun and the way that he's broke all he
had an episode on Fantasy Factory where
he like broke nine World Records or
something like that just because I love
people who do just dumb stuff just
because it seems fun so I think Rob
Dyrdek is up there you have uh Joe Rogan
he seems like he's living his life
all right what are the five things you
you most enjoy doing he's like I love
comedy love UFC I love talking to smart
people and learning new [__]
um I love hunting you know and then he's
just like cool that's my life it built
he integrated his his career his life
and his friends to be the same thing
like his friends are other Comedians and
um and then it's like and and people in
the UFC his career is like oh well I'll
just be the top broadcaster in the UFC
the top podcaster and then I'll be one
of the top 20 comedians like that sounds
great like they'll make a bunch of money
and I'll get to do my art like that
sounds fun and then any a Drew
boundaries he's like um
yeah I love the UFC but I'm not
traveling to like Senegal for this
pay-per-view like I only do the ones
like within a two-hour flight of me or
that's it like that's my rule and I'm
just gonna do that and I'm okay with not
doing the rest and I love that you said
he's yeah he's not divorced it seems
like he's got his head on straight like
I really think he's having a lot of fun
I admire that Bill Simmons is kind of
the same way he's basically that for
sports and then my uncle Vinnie I got an
uncle Vinnie who's literally his
nickname that was given to him was
Smiley so he signs all his signatures
Vinnie quote Smiley
um and he's just or he'll just sign it
smiley and like this one definitely just
been in the banks like uh sir I don't
think you could do that he's I don't
know 70 something years old and if you
hear him he's like I'm getting younger
every day he's like I'm so excited he
wakes up at four in the morning with no
alarm because he's so excited about the
day and like even even though the things
he was he's doing like he's like I'm so
excited I'm doing this webinar about
multi-family real estate right now it's
like it's not what I would enjoy doing
and it's not even something that to the
outside sounds super glamorous but the
point is he is he is excited about it he
is having the most fun in his life like
he he wears what he wants he dresses the
way he wants he talks the way he wants
he does what he wants with his time he
travels the way he wants it and I just
feel like uh that guy his Joy meter is
like you know permanently stuck on on
like Max and so I kind of admire that
because with Joe Rogan it's easy to say
man yeah if I if I also had the best
podcast and the UFC and all these
hobbies and great friends like yeah I
would be having a lot of fun too and my
Uncle Vinnie's a great example because
he doesn't have anything that like is
the he doesn't have a lifestyle that's
like you know some celebrity or
something like that
and he's having all the fun like now and
I think that's great because he's not
waiting to achieve all this [__] to have
fun he's having it now
what type of Indian guy has the name of
Vinnie is that are those real names
and then he went Vinnie
to like make it more like acceptable in
America when he moved here and then they
just were like bro this guy's never
stopped smiling so his whole company
just called him Smiley and then you know
that was like that was the whole thing
we we name one time in Austin we had
this really bad office that had rats and
we Nick and we had them and we nicknamed
Vinnie and Vinnie was an Italian guy
like and they would come in at night
like oh hey the fat guy left us some
cheese
and that was the name of our office rat
was viddy Eddie video from New York and
uh that's what I think if you have it
named an office ratter Mouse okay you
haven't grinded have you lived you're
not on that right
um all right q a this is the easiest
stuff ever to talk about so maybe we
should just do this every time now I
know why Gary vaynerchuk did that the
whole show was asking garyvee right all
you have to do is just like answer dumb
questions yeah this was fun we should do
more
um all right that's the pod
[Music]
thank you